working things out right yeah i mean i i
would be like okay this this looks like
still uh you know you've only got one
pawn now and it's like right you have to
be very careful about your calculation
here i mean um
i i'm surprised by this actually i think
magnus is going for something that he's
studied before i've seen this end game
with a king and a pawn on this square
and white's knight completely stuck
stopping the black pawn and all you need
to do as black is relocate your knight
distract the white knight and then your
pawn promotes to a queen so i think
magnus
had it worked out pretty much or has
seen something very similar to this
before seen this pattern yeah it's
incredible again how he just finishes
the game off you know even here it's
like wow he knows this is a win and he's
got it he's got zugswang swang no matter
what white does you will lose the white
knight it's game over and artemiev i
think has just resigned so impressive
he's so impressive in these positions
where so many times i've written him off
as it's just been a draw and then he
just you know